[Musique]
ton père et j'ai tellement qu'ils
m'avaient fait cette vidéo comme on va
dionne un petit bonhomme je te le dit
nicole ce petit un truc spécial tu es un
adorable petit garçon tu es intelligent
super gentil est super beau gosse sont
[Musique]
pas te dit que tu avais parlé de ton
père maman m'a jamais dit ce qui s'est
passé elle a juste parlé d'un orage
pas vraiment quelque chose de bizarre
[Musique]
devrait chercher un moyen de les
contrôler combien de temps tu penses
pouvoir le cacher ici
le gouvernement traque tous les gens qui
ont des super pouvoirs
[Musique]
je sais quelques petites choses sur dieu
je crois que les tempêtes sont attirés
par notre vie
vi madame vous
m
je suis ta maman oui mais qui dit
d'accord
[Musique]